اذا المساعد دبلوماسيه التي حملها ماكرون
في زيارته الاخيره لوشنطن بخصوص الحرف
اوكرانيا يمكن ان لا ترى النور خصوصا وان
مواقفه تجاه روسيا تغيرت وهو ما اثار غضب
اوكرانيا وبعض حلفائها بعد ان شدد على
ضروره تقديم ضمانات امنيه لروسيا كجزء من
اي مفاوضات فالتصريحات العلنيه للرئيس
الفرنسي تراها واشنطن غير مبرره خصوصا
وانه اكد في اكثر من مناسبه بان الولايات
المتحده لن تحترم دول اوروبا كحلفاء الا
اذا كانت شؤونها الدفاعيه ذات سياده
لا يجب الاعتماد على الحلف بل يجب العمل
معه حتى نتمكن من اعاده التفكير في
استقلاليه
في عام 2018 لتاسيس جيش اوروبي موحد بعيد
عن حلف شمال الاطلسي ومستقل عن اي نفوذ
امريكي من سر الى العلم كما وصف الناتو
بالحلف الميت سريريا وهو ما اثار حفيظه
الولايات المتحده التي تعتبر نفسها عنصرا
مهما
على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يبدا محادثات
الخاصه مع روسيا بدلا من الاعتماد على
واشنطن لتجنب اكثر الامور ماساويه في
الحرب
بضروره تشكيل جيش الاوروبي ذلك من خلال
تقديم مخطط عسكري يهدف الى تشكيل اول وحده
عسكريه تشمل 5000 عسكري مدعومه بسفن
وطائرات حربيه
واسلحه ثقيله يطلق عليها اسم قوه الدخول
الاول
وبالتالي فهو يسعى لتهميش دوري امريكا في
القضايا الاوروبيه اذ لم ينسى الرئيس
الفرنسي صفقه الغواصات لاستراليا التي
اعتبرتها باريس بمثابه خيانه عظمى لها
[موسيقى]